before I introduce mr. Jack Valenti the
president of the Motion Picture
Association of America I'd like to say
to you people at home who are taping
this on your Betamax you're all under
arrest and now to present the Jean
Hersholt Humanitarian Award mr. Jack
Valenti
the Jean Hersholt award is the Academy's
most treasured humanitarian prize and
this year it goes to Leo Jaffe the
chairman of the board of Columbia
Pictures in just a few weeks time he
marks his 50th year with that company
certainly nobody can accuse him of
flitting around to mr. Jaffee words like
duty honor excellence caring for others
a crucial rules of life too often in our
times these words are bruised by
inattention or disfigured by callous
neglect but to mr. Jaffe their beacon
lights to live by I know of no one in
our industry more worthy of receiving
the Jean Hersholt Humanitarian Award
ladies and gentlemen mr. Leo Jaffe
thank you jack for gracious introduction
and remarks I am indeed overwhelmed by
this prestigious meaningful award I
thank each and every member of the
Academy and the Board of Directors for
the honor being bestowed upon me tonight
I appreciate the support given to me by
my colleagues and associates at Columbia
Pictures I also take this opportunity to
publicly thank my gracious wife Anita my
children and grandchildren for their
understanding and constant support and
often sacrifices and enabling me to
participate in this work that is so dear
to me while our vast audience throughout
the world look to our industry to
provide entertainment it is important to
stress the fact we often overlooked that
all segments of the industry are
responsible people who are very
responsive to the communal needs and
other problems that confront us they
give generously of their time talents
and efforts and financial resources to
many worthwhile causes be they
philanthropic Civic or educational that
will help improve the quality of life I
am proud to be part of an industry that
there's so much for so many thank you
all for making it such a memorable
evening for me